OPPOSERS, I HAVE BEEN SO BUSY
WITH THE NORTH KOREA SUMMIT THAT
I AM JUST NOW CATCHING UP ON MY
D.V.R.
APPARENTLY, OTHER THINGS
HAPPENED THIS WEEK-- LIKE MY OLD
NEMESIS, THE TONY AWARDS.
NOW, I'VE HATED THE THEATRE EVER
SINCE I WAS FORCED TO SIT
THROUGH THAT TWO-HOUR PIECE OF
RECYCLING PROPAGANDA.
(  LAUGHTER  )
BUT IT WASN'T TRASH CANS THAT
WERE GETTING RHYTHMICALLY BANGED
ON AT THIS SHOW.
IT WAS OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
IT STARTED WITH A DISRESPECTFUL
RED CARPET INTERVIEW WITH A STAR
OF "HARRY POTTER AND THE CURSED
CHILD."
>> WE, AS ALL, AS HUMAN BEINGS,
ARE FIGHTING TO BE CONNECTED,
BUT ESPECIALLY TO BE SEEN.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS PLAY IS
ABOUT.
>> SHOULD THE PRESIDENT COME SEE
THE "HARRY POTTER"-- "HARRY
POTTER AND THE CURSED CHILD?"
>> NO.
>> Jordan: I'VE GOT NEWS FOR
YOU.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T WANT TO
COME SEE YOUR STUPID BRITISH
PLAY!
HE'S AMERICAN.
HE ONLY WANTS TO SEE PLAYS IN
ENGLISH.
(  LAUGHTER  )
( APPLAUSE )
YES!
I'LL TELL YOU WHO THE REAL
VILLAIN HERE IS:  THE MONSTERS
CHARGING $300 A TICKET FOR A
PLAY THAT YOU'VE CONVENIENTLY
SPLIT INTO TWO PARTS.
$600 FOR ONE PLAY?
FOR 600 BUCKS, I'LL COME TO YOUR
HOUSE AND READ YOU ALL THE HARRY
POTTER BOOKS.
(  LAUGHTER  )
I'LL EVEN DO THE VOICES.
( TERRIBLE BRITISH ACCENT )
OI!
MAGIC!
( NORMAL VOICE )
PERFECT.
PAY UP.
BUT THAT WAS JUST THE FIRST ACT
OF THE MAGA HATE.
HERE COMES THE SHOW STOPPER.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
ROBERT DE NIRO.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY ONE THING:
(BLEEP) TRUMP.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jordan: NO, NOT THIS, THIS!
NOT YOU, BOBBY DE NIRO!
A CINEMATIC LEGEND WHO FAMOUSLY
SAID, "I HAVE NIPPLES, GREG.
CAN YOU MILK ME?"
I LOVE "TAXI DRIVER."
(  LAUGHTER  )
BUT HE CROSSED THE LINE AND THE
PRESIDENT HIT BACK.
>> THE PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT
SOMETHING.
"ROBERT DE NIRO, A VERY LOW I.Q.
INDIVIDUAL, HAS RECEIVED TOO
MANY SHOTS TO THE HEAD BY REAL
BOXERS IN MOVIES.
I WATCHED HIM LAST NIGHT AND
TRULY BELIEVE HE MAY BE
PUNCH-DRUNK."
WAKE UP PUNCHY.
PUNCHY IS THE NEW NICKNAME FOR
ROBERT DE NIRO.
>> Jordan: CABLE NEWS IS
ENTERING IT'S FINAL, MOST
BEAUTIFUL FORM: A TRUMP NICKNAME
REPORTING SERVICE.
(  LAUGHTER  )
BIG SURPRISE, DE NIRO GOT A HUGE
STANDING OVATION FROM THE
SEQUINED SHEEP.
BUT THERE IS ONE PLACE IN NEW
YORK WHERE REAL AMERICA PUSHES
BACK:  STATEN ISLAND.
>> THIS USED TO BE MY IDOL.
I USED TO LOVE THIS GUY,
ROBERT DE NIRO.
BUT AFTER WHAT HE DID LAST NIGHT
AT THE TONYS, THIS IS WHERE
ROBERT GOES.
THIS IS WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE THINK OF
YOU.
YOU'RE A REAL PIECE OF SHIT.
>> Jordan: MY HERO!
THE TAE KWON DO BASEBALL JERSEY,
A FRAMED PICTURE OF
ROBERT DE NIRO.
THE ONLY WAY THIS VIDEO COULD BE
MORE STATEN ISLAND IS IF HE WAS
ALSO EATING A SLICE OF PIZZA AND
FIGHTING A LITTLE LEAGUE COACH.
(  LAUGHTER  )
AND THANK GOD HE HAD JUST THE
TOOL FOR THE JOB.
WHAT I BELIEVE IS TECHNICALLY
CALLED A "STATEN ISLAND REVENGE
HAMMER."
(  LAUGHTER  )
SO I HOPE YOU ENJOYED YOUR
LITTLE PARTY, EAST COAST
HOLLYWOOD, BECAUSE CONSERVATIVES
MAY NOT HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
TONYS, BUT WE'LL ALWAYS HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF AN ISLAND FULL OF
ANTHONYS.